- Greetings. My name is Timothy Snyder.
I'm the Levin Professor of
History at Yale University.
I am greeting and
welcoming you this evening
on behalf of the Franke program,
which has enabled me
along with my colleague,
Professor Jason Stanley,
to teach a seminar this
semester on mass incarceration
in the Soviet Union and the United States.
This is the last of these
lectures that I'll be introducing.
So I want to make a special
point of thanking Richard
and Barbara Franke for their support
of the humanities in particular at Yale.
This is much appreciated
in general, in particular,
I've been very glad to be
able to teach this class.
So this seminar on mass
incarceration in USSR
and in the US is getting
towards its middle point.
At this point, our students
have spent a couple of weeks
reading about the origins of the Gulag
and the functioning of the Gulag.
This week, you who are not our students,
are joining us as we
move on to the subject
of the experience of the Gulag.
One of the most important
chroniclers of the Soviet camps
was a Polish artist whose
name was Józef Czapski.
Józef Czapski was, until a few years ago,
someone who was idolized by, I would say,
the best part of the
Polish intelligentsia.
Thanks to our speaker this
evening, Eric Karpeles,
Józef Czapski has moved from being someone
who was known to a few
as an outstanding painter
and chronicler of the 20th century,
to become a figure who can be now
and is becoming now
much more widely known.
I'm a historian and I've
always understood Jozef Czapski
in terms of his experiences,
but Eric Karpeles,
who is himself an artist and a translator,
as well as a writer,
someone who found Czapski
by way of Proust, which is
an extraordinary connection.
When Czapski was in a Soviet camp,
he was allowed to give French lessons
and he did so in the
form of recapitulating
remembrance of things passed
by Proust, which is for me,
one of the most extraordinary
civilizational achievements
imaginable and deep and
profound in all kinds of ways.
But Eric Karpeles came to Czapski
from a different direction.
He came to Czapski by way
of Proust and by way of art
and discovered or
rediscovered him as a painter
and then has contributed, in fact,
essentially all by himself,
has created a revival of
Józef Czapski in the west
in the English language by
re-translating the lecture notes
that Czapski gave about
Proust in the Soviet camp,
by compiling the art into
an extraordinarily beautiful
volume which I'm going to
bring to class tomorrow,
and by writing an accessible
and, even for for who thought
he thought he knew the life pretty well,
a striking and original
and persuasive biography
of Czapski called Almost Nothing,
which I'm going to do
my duty and hold up now.
People speak of dog-eared
copies as though it's a cliche,
but you can see is
actually a dog-eared copy.
So at this point in the
class, we're very welcome,
we're very, very happy to be
able to welcome Eric Karpeles.
We're trying to consider what
it would be like to experience
and think about and see the
Gulag and Jozef Czapski,
there could be no better
figure than Jozef Czapski
for that, but more than that,
the class needs to reach a point
where we understand that
the people who experienced
the Gulag are experiencing it thoughtfully
by way of other things they bring to it,
that their lives are not just determined
by this experience of incarceration.
Jozef Czapski's an example
of someone for whom
incarceration was very
important for himself,
but perhaps more so for his
friends and his comrades
and his colleagues who he
later tried to remember,
but he was above all an artist who
lived an almost century-long life.
So I'm very pleased at
this point in the class,
we're going to be able to
seriously introduce art
as part of the history or part
of the approach to mass incarceration.
This is a theme and then
approach alongside philosophy
and history, which I hope
we'll be able to keep going.
So there's no one better to do this
for us than Eric Karpeles, Eric,
I'm very glad that you
were able to join us.
I welcome you on behalf of all the people
whom who can see you
but whom you can't see,
and I'm very much looking
forward to your lecture
and to your presentation. Thank you.
- It's certainly an honor
to see a copy of my book
read by you with those dog-eared pages.
It makes a great impression upon me.
I will say that right now,
I need to see how, so Józef
Czapski: Facing the Void.
I have chosen the title as a way
of expressing the context of this class
and the way in which Czapski can
interact with the subject at large.
Facing the Void is in one
way of looking at the world,
the 20th century, which
Czapski lived through.
He lived into his 97th year,
and also a way of the
internal life of Czapski
in which he always felt the need
to create as a way of filling the void,
as a way of making comment
on the world around him.
Czapski was an enormously large character.
He will fit very tightly, be shoehorned,
into this short lecture of mine,
which could actually warrant
an entire semester of study.
So without a lot of further
do, I'm just going to jump in.
I've been asked by
Professor Snyder to put him
in a context of the world in
which the class takes place,
and also to speak about him as an artist,
which I feel more comfortable in,
but I will run you through all of this.
So we're going to begin
with this is the world
in which Czapski was born in 1896.
It's a map of Central and
Eastern Europe and Russia.
And it rightly suggests the very specific
and firm international imperial borders.
But it fails to note that
beyond these borders,
cultural and societal
norms were transgressed,
that this was not something
that stopped at a border,
that these societies all
interacted with each other.
Czapski's family was
just outside of Minsk,
where their lands were, and this is what
today is known as Belarus.
the home in which Czapski
grew up, his childhood home.
Here he is with his parents on the left
and his five sisters and one brother.
His mother was an Austrian countess,
and his father was a Polish count,
a Polish count who grew up
speaking French and German
and Russian, but who only
learned Polish at university.
This was a world peopled by
highly cosmopolitan individuals,
citizens of the world rather than people
defined by a single national identity.
Czapski had Russian, Baltic,
Czech, and German cousins.
He was born in Prague in 1896
in one of his mother's family's palaces.
It was a great life of privilege.
It was his mother, the
Austrian countess, however,
who decided that her
children should be raised
as what she'd like to
call her little Poles.
When he turned 13, Czapski
and his younger brother
were shipped off to St. Petersburg
to improve their Russian,
with the expectation of
their time would come to run
the family estate and to
prepare for the baccalaureate.
Five years later, in
1914, the first World War
was systematically destroying
the old life of Europe,
slaughtering a generation of young men.
Czapski, still in Petersburg,
and deeply immersed in
Tolstoyan spiritualism,
he was very young and
he was very vulnerable
and Tolstoy meant a great deal to him.
And he wrestled with his feelings
about religion, about God,
but to keep them from being
sent to the front as war fodder,
Czapski's father enrolled his two boys
in the elite military training school,
the (indistinct) in St. Petersburg.
This self portrait, which
was drawn at the time,
was the first of a long
line of self portraits.
Czapski presented himself
as a military cadet
and a young man of the world.
He was still in Petersburg
when both the February
and October revolutions erupted in 1917,
and he was deeply marked
by the experience.
He returned to Warsaw in 1918 and decided
to pursue a course of study in painting
rather than to continue on
with his training as a pianist.
In February of 1919, tensions exploded
between the newly-minted
Second Republic of Poland
and Soviet Russia, not
yet the Soviet Union.
Abandoning his course of study at the
Fine Arts Academy in Warsaw,
Czapski volunteered immediately
for military service.
His courage in combat
earned him the Polish
Order of the Virtuti Militari,
the country's highest military decoration.
He received this medal at the same time
as a French officer would
become a friend of his.
Charles de Gaulle would have been
sent to Poland as an observer.
The friendship survived
over the decades to come.
Back from the front, he enrolled at
the Academy of Fine Arts in Krakow,
a city where he knew no one.
Czapski would recall, I entered the world
of my new friends where an
intellectual atmosphere,
marked by a carefree
assurance of winning optimism
and essential joy (indistinct),
was totally alien to me.
Czapski, as you can see in this picture,
grew to enormous heights. He
was six feet, six inches tall.
Everyone, however, knew
him as (indistinct),
which is an affectionate
diminutive of the name Jozef.
It's one of those contradictions
that Czapski's life
was full of, but largely it's the sense
of the scale of him that's
so impressive, always.
As a painting student he was
caught between the historical
religious requirements of the
traditional Polish painting,
and at the same time, what
was going on in Warsaw
was the fashionable
leaning towards post-cubic,
Cubist ideological movements
like Futurism and Formism.
Neither of these was
particularly appealing to him
as a painter, as a painting student,
and he and a group of like-minded
students bonded together.
They raised money hoping
they could finance
a trip to spend six weeks in Paris,
where all the action was in painting.
They felt they were in a backwater.
They recognized that and hoped to move on.
They gave a ball to raise money.
They did all sorts of fundraising things,
and they raised enough money
to spend six weeks in Paris.
They succeeded and departed for Paris,
but instead of staying six
weeks, they stayed seven years.
They became known as
the Committee of Paris
and ever after they returned to Poland,
they were known as the Kapists.
Czapski's seven years in Paris
were enormously important.
They were marked by his immersion
and the painting of Bonnard, Matisse.
The groups attending professor,
the painter Jozef Pankiewicz,
who is shown in the self portrait on
the bottom left of the screen,
was an old friend of Bonnard.
The two of them used to
go to the south together
every summer and paint side by side.
It was a time in which he
shared with his sister,
Maria, who became
enormously important to him.
And the two of them were together
for most of their lives, their long lives.
She was also as tall as
he, she was very striking.
She became an historian.
Eventually the Polish
painters had the excitement
of their own tourist exhibition,
which gained them praise
from such recognized figures
as Dufy, Rouault, and
even Bonnard himself.
Czapski was able to sell
his first paintings,
including one to Gertrude Stein.
On the right, you see the image
of what's called the
(indistinct), which is,
that building was where
the painters communally met
every day to work in studio space.
There were many influences
on Czapski at the time.
He had come to Paris to see
the real painting going on.
In the following groups of
slides, I've shown on the left,
a known painter in Czapski's work
that somehow shows the
influence and the effect
of coming in contact with
this kind of painting.
Here's Cezanne. The fellow on the right,
the portrait is of a
man named (indistinct),
who was an art critic that Czapski knew.
Here is a Matisse on the left,
and on the right we see Czapski's
closest attempt at Fauvism.
This is a way in which
you see the influence
of technique of color, of form,
learning from the masters.
Soutine, Czapski on the right.
Czapski on the left in this case.
You can see him painting
with a certain crude stroke,
and yet with a great animation of vitality
and of an interest in color.
Bonnard was a terrific
influence on Czapski.
These works on paper with
pencil and watercolor
and colored pencil, but primarily
in the intensity of the
color in his canvases.
In 1930, after having
mounted the group exhibition
of the galleries art, Czapski
headed to Spain for six weeks.
In the vast halls of the Prado,
he had what he called
the shock of my life.
Standing before the huge array
of works by Goya, he was overwhelmed.
His masterful portraits of great ladies,
dignitaries, cardinals and kings,
are painted so smoothly to the degree
that you don't feel the brush.
They're classical in
composition and miraculous
in the control of every
detail, Czapski wrote.
And in the materiality of the object,
in the consideration given to local
colors and the gradation of values.
Next to these portraits, in another room,
hung badly, were paintings by Goya
so extremely different that
it was difficult to believe
they were painted by the same person.
War scenes, wild scenes
with which is so frenzied.
We see all the brush strokes.
Color contrast is violent.
They rival Soutine.
And the disdain for local
color and the objects
materiality such that the
canvas is sometimes giving
the impression of almost
abstract color relations.
Speaking of myself, Czapski went on,
I was long tormented by
a duality of approach.
Analytic on the one hand, rational,
growing from the Dutch tradition.
And on the other hand, the
mad, the unpredictable,
the true leap into the abyss.
In this, I saw a lack of
integrated personality in myself.
A kind of psychic dividedness that I tried
to overcome artificially without success,
but then I noticed the same
phenomenon in the painter
who's statue was not only
equal to that in the Matisse,
but who was one of the very
greatest. I speak about Goya.
In 1931 the group of Polish
painters returned to Poland.
Czapski set up a studio in
Warsaw and entered directly
into the flow of the artistic scene there.
He began to write about painting as well,
and to exhibit his work on a yearly basis.
We find that his work from these years,
the seed of the French style,
transplanted into Polish soil,
taking root, bearing fruit.
These paintings tend to
conform to a range of stylistic
options that feel imposed from without,
tried on like various guises,
rather than emanating from
somewhere within strengthened.
Strengthened by Goya's example,
Czapski is nevertheless still finding
his way, learning as he goes.
These paintings were done at a time
when the Bloomsbury group painters
were actually very closely
experimenting in the same way
with changing old painting styles.
Here's Czapski coming down the hallway.
You can see that yellow bar
about a third of the way up
from the bottom of the
canvas, across the canvas,
which is not quite opaque in
which you can see the turn
of the carpet coming
towards you down the hall.
Czapski is still learning his medium here.
In the mid 1930s, Czapski met a young
writer named Ludwig Hering.
In their own tortured way, they overcame
their constraining religious
scruples and allowed themselves
to fall in love, to set up
home as far as was possible
from so oppressive an environment.
Knowledge of this unconventional setup
of what was perceived as their
flaunting of societal norms
is what has continued to this day to mute
the response of the community in Poland
to Czapski's achievements and his
indisputable historical significance.
The two men had several
heartening, emotional,
nurturing years together and
remained in close spiritual
contact until the death of Hering, who,
ill with cancer,
committed suicide in 1984.
This is one of Czapski's paintings
just before war broke out, 1937.
This is the promenade on the Baltic Sea,
just outside of what was
then known as Danzig.
You can see the Nazi
flags along the promenade.
On September 1st, Poland
was invaded by Germany
in the air, on the ground, the sea.
September 2nd, the next day,
Czapski went to join his cavalry regiment
as a reserve officer, aged 43.
On the 27th of September,
he and his regimen
were surrounded by
Germans outside of Lviv.
Surprisingly, they were handed
over to the Russian forces
who had invaded Poland
from the east on the 16th.
He spent six months at
Starobielsk, in Ukraine,
as a prisoner of war in a
camp with at first 11,000
fellow prisoners under severe conditions
of crowding and lack of
food in the first months.
In June of 1940, he
was finally transferred
with very few other of
his prisoner colleagues
to a camp at (indistinct),
north of Moscow.
There's a self portrait he
made in camp (indistinct).
This is the beginning of
our understanding of Czapski
and his relationship to
drawing and to his journals.
He kept a journal throughout the war,
which became a source
of much of his writing
and of his memory of the experience.
In the book by Julius
Margolin that you're also
reading for this class, he
says that no one in the camps,
no one retains his original form.
Observation is difficult because
the observer himself is deformed.
This was a test that
Czapski had set himself
in an attempt not to become deformed,
to remain true to himself and to help
his fellow prisoners also keep
focused and keep true to themselves.
They were constantly
bombarded by Soviet propaganda
over loud speakers in the camp,
but they struggled to
keep true to themselves.
Czapski's war was not the
same, certainly, as Margolin's.
There were different territories
and different demands
upon each of them, but there was something
about Czapski's resistance
to the hammering of Soviet
propaganda that's very inspiring.
In Russia, paper was enormously valuable.
It was not of good quality,
but it was very rare and hard to come by.
He did whatever he could to get
notebooks and he filled them.
This is a drawing of
his friends in the camp,
a man named Adam Shinski.
This is a drawing on both
sides of one piece of paper.
I'm showing both sides of it.
He filled every page he could.
And got pencils as he could
and materials as he could.
But painting was out of
the question, really.
Drawing and use of watercolors was what
he had at hand and he made the best of it.
More drawings of prison companions.
He wrote the sense of being totally unsure
if we would ever see
anything again in our lives
apart from barbed wire fences
and this alien hostile world.
The sense of being buried alive was cruel.
It seemed very unlikely that we would ever
get beyond the wire unless to get
a bullet in the back of the head.
Professor Snyder made
reference to the French lessons
that Czapski was able to give.
This is his French notebook for
those lectures that he gave.
He decided to lecture Herisod every night,
tell a little bit of the portion of
Proust's great novel,
In Search of Lost Time.
He took extensive notes,
which are in themselves
quite beautiful drawings.
If you know Proust, you can
see a little bit on the left,
some of the names of the characters,
but the sketch itself, the
diagram in which he unfolds
Czapski like a cosmology,
is in both Polish and French
and German and Russian.
Different pages carrying
different diagrams.
This was an understanding for Czapski
of the attempt to
remember what he had read.
He read Proust in the
'20s when he was in Paris
as each of the volumes came out,
he was in a Soviet camp
where he had no books,
no access to the material.
So in order to speak about Proust,
he had to remember Proust.
And this is in a way a
kind of manifestation
of the very Proustian enterprise,
the attempt to recall the past and to make
use of it in the present.
He wrote an intellectual effort conducted
without books or notes
gives an entirely different
sensation then when carried
out under normal conditions.
Once involuntary memory
acts much more forcefully,
the memory of which Proust speaks,
in which he considered to be
the sole source of literary creation.
After a certain amount of time,
things surface in our consciousnesses.
Details we haven't the slightest idea
were even stored anywhere in our brain.
What is more, these memories that arise
from our subconscious
are more deeply rooted,
more intimately bound up
with another, more personal.
Czapski helps his fellow
prisoners to again
nurture themselves, their interior lives,
and to use this experience
of sharing Proust
as a way of hardening them
against the realities outside,
and nurturing their inner lives.
On June 22nd, 1941,
everything was upended.
To this day, Czapski wrote,
I can still hear ringing in my ears,
a scruffy Colonel bending his
upper body from the window,
shouting, Hitler attack Russia.
A new phase of the war began.
Stalin provisionally agreed
to free all Polish prisoners
and deportees in order
to form an independent
Polish army within the Red Army to fight
their former ally, now their common enemy.
General Wladyslaw Anders,
confined in Moscow's
notorious Lubyanka prison,
where he had been tortured and
spent 27 months in solitary,
had been chosen to command
the new Polish order.
He had no shoes. He
walked slowly from wounds
inflicted by beatings, and
he wore a prison uniform.
On that day he was introduced
to two of Russia's most
powerful Politburo members,
(indistinct) and Beria,
who escorted him to a
limousine where he was whisked
to meetings about the formation of a new
Polish division of the Red Army.
Soldier-prisoners began to
gather from all the vast corners
of the Gulag to join
the new Polish division.
But most of the officers never reappeared.
Czapski was assigned to interrogate
the new arrivals to investigate
what had become of their officers,
but thousands of thousands
of rank and file soldiers
passed by his desk and
produced not one link
to the whereabouts of a single officer.
Anders then ordered Czapski to find them,
arming him with letters of introduction
from the Commander of the Polish Army.
For months, he traveled
across the Soviet Union
in search of news of these men.
But over and over again,
he ran straight into a wall of silence.
In the meantime,
Stalin was determined
to send these new Polish
recruits to the front, but the men,
poorly fed, inadequately armed,
and unable to train for combat
having just been released
from a year and a half of
deprivation and squalor.
Anders resisted Stalin's pressure
and insisted the men be suitably recovered
and trained for the
current conditions of war.
By order of Anders, Czapski
was named chief officer
of information and propaganda
for the Polish Army.
And he had the considerable distinction
of being in daily contact with Anders,
his commander-in-chief.
When it became clear that a standoff
had happened in the spring of 1942,
Stalin agreed to let the Polish troops
evacuate to Iran, where they would be fed
by British rations, and
then move on to Iraq.
This map shows the routes
taken by Anders' army
and by Czapski from his
capture in September, 1939,
over the course of the
next five and a half years.
This is an enormous undertaking
to move all of these men.
Throughout the war, Czapski
continued to keep his journal,
making elaborate notes, drawing
people and scenes he witnessed.
On the left is an album from
these years in the middle east.
Graniczhy means borderlands.
Uzbekistan, Turkmenistan, Kazakhstan,
all of the places that the Polish army
had been stationed before its exodus.
On the right is journal
once they arrived in Egypt.
One night in Tashkent,
he was invited to a literary gathering
where he encountered the
Russian poet Anna Akhmatova,
who's poems Czapski knew well.
At this time, her poetry
was revered by many,
but officially reviled,
considered decadent and bourgeois
by the reigning authorities
on aesthetic taste.
Her work was banned by the regime
and she could no longer publish.
Czapski was surprised to find her,
widow of a poet murdered by the state,
sitting quietly, if aloof,
in a Soviet officer's private home.
Czapski was asked to
read some Polish poetry,
which he then translated into Russian.
Ms. Akhmatova listened
intently, tears in her eyes.
He gently persuaded her to
share some of her poems.
Czapski learned that Stalin himself
admired some of Akhmatova's work.
And it was he personally
who ensured her safety.
In the presence of this
elegant strong woman
with her sharp alert mind,
Czapski found evidence
of nearly schizophrenia
atmosphere imposed on the closed
society of Russian artists.
Czapski was the first non-Russian
Akhmatova had met in over 20 years.
That night they walked together,
late at night after dinner,
and stayed up until dawn speaking.
Years later Czapski wrote that she
had written a poem about that night,
about the impact of his presence upon her.
They met once more in 1965,
as she was returning from
receiving a doctorate
at Oxford on her way back to Russia.
She had ditched her Soviet escort,
had gone directly to Paris, and saw him.
Czapski was in Iraq on April 13th, 1943,
when radio Berlin broadcast
the news of the discovery
of mass graves in a
forest in Western Russia.
These were some of the men, I'm sorry.
I'm still bringing Czapski
through the middle east here,
drawing as he goes, documenting his trip.
Aspects of travel, aspect of daily life,
and an army full of men at repose,
playing soccer, bathing, showering.
These are some of the men Czapski
had been devoted to finding,
among them many close friends.
Broadcasts from radio Berlin
had announced the graves.
This is what was dug up.
These were scenes of outside
of Katyn in the forest
of the bodies of Polish
officers who were still in their
gray coats shot in the back of the head.
Forever after, for the next 50 years,
Czapski would make it his duty
to remind the world of the
fate of 22,000 of these
Polish officers and civilians.
Polish army pushed on out of
the middle east to Jerusalem
and Tel Aviv, eventually
to Cairo and Port Sayeed,
where they boarded ships
for the Italian peninsula.
Czapski was at Anders'
side during the planning
for the assault on Germans who had dug in
for months at monastery at Monte Cassino,
ceaselessly bombed by the
Allies in hopes of dislodging
them and opening the road to Rome.
You can see in the picture on the bottom,
the grossly remains of the monastery,
which had once been such
a beautiful retreat.
The Poles, in their
first foray at soldiering
since leaving the Soviet Union,
fought valiantly and at
a great loss of life,
but succeeded in uprooting the Germans.
On the morning of the 18th,
the monastery was theirs.
Czapski had few illusions about the Allies
for whom the big news that season was
the invasion of Normandy
and the liberation of Paris.
From the Poles, still traumatized
by the discovery of the Katyn massacre,
the most important
event of the late spring
of 1944 was the Warsaw uprising.
Czapski's sister Maria
had remained in Warsaw
through the methodical destruction
of most of the city by Nazi troops,
As Czapski feared, all of his
work that he had stored away
before leaving to join his
regiment in September, 1939,
his paintings, his writings, his diaries,
was destroyed along with so much else.
His sense of unease about the
Allies proved well justified.
In February of 1945 at
the Yalta conference,
Stalin solidified his iron grip on Poland.
Still in Rome with the Anders army,
Czapski published a memoir
of his prison experience.
Memories of Starobielsk,
drawn from his daily journal,
attended to throughout
his years as a soldier.
A friend who had been a
prisoner in the labor camp
in Siberia the same time described
Czapski's account of
life as a prisoner as,
lived by a Pole, meditated
on by a European,
written by a painter.
The book was printed and
circulated just as the war ended
and was largely ignored
or met with hostility
by both Soviets and Allies.
As the army of Anders
broke up in Rome in 1945,
Czapski and a group of
his like-minded friends
determined that they would create
an institute called the
Polish Literary Institute.
They decided to base it in Paris.
They put their funds together
and came up with a home.
Not this one, this is the second home,
but outside of Paris in a quiet suburb
called Maisons-Laffitte, and this house,
which is almost iconic in
Russian cultural history,
still stands today and is still the home
of the Polish Literary Institute.
Czapski took up residence
in this upper floor,
in this room with the open
window at the back of the house.
It was to be his library, his salon,
and his painting studio
for the next 50 years.
All of the work from here on will have
come out from this little room.
Men like (indistinct),
shown here with Czapski,
these and others after months
and months of conversations
as soldiers of the Anders
army created the institute
once the army was disbanded.
They invested no faith in the
redemptive powers of the west.
They fully understood the
corrosive shadow cast at Yalta.
Czapski and (indistinct),
and a handful of other dedicated souls,
created from nothing the
magazine called Kultura.
One of the most influential
and widely read journals
of the 20th century.
Kultura had an astonishing
run of 637 issues, spanning
53 year window of time.
Looking back, Kultura was
synonymous with Poland itself,
acting in local (indistinct)
for the Polish institutions
denied the right to exist on
the ground in Poland itself.
The first issue shown on
the left here included works
by Lorca, (indistinct), Arthur Koestler.
Czapski debuted with a tribute to Bonnard,
who had recently died.
Czapski was torn between
his cosmopolitan self
and the Polish role of events
the war foisted on him.
He only reluctantly embraced a nationalism
that ran counter to his
instinctual bohemianism.
He overcame that resistance
and in his creative response
to it he wrote a memoir
called Inhuman Land.
You've read some of these
pages for this class.
Czapski said that I was not
free to write what I wanted,
but I needed to write what I must.
It was difficult getting
him in that publishing
reflective state of a French left's
tenacious romance with Stalinism.
Failing to find a publisher,
Czapski's book was excerpted in the second
and third issues of Kultura.
Only two years later in 1949,
his old friend Daniel Halevy
finally found a publisher
willing to print the entire book
if someone else paid for
the cost of publication.
Despite encouragement from Arthur Koestler
and George Orwell, no English
publisher would touch it.
David Rousset was a
left-wing French journalist
and authority on Nazi concentration camps,
a survivor of Buchenwald and Neuengamme.
His expose of those worlds, called,
The Truth About the Camps,
had been well-received,
yet a review of Rousset's
book by art critic and editor
Pierre Daix claimed that he was
slandering the Soviet Union,
and was making false claims against it.
Rousset sued for libel.
At the trial, Czapski
appeared as a witness,
answering questions about
his years in Starobielsk.
The lawyers for Daix tried to undermine
his credibility as a witness.
Going further and holding
forth about the murders
of his fellow Poles in Katyn,
Czapski stung the courtroom,
enraging the defense team
and unleashing an uproar.
The judge was forced to call a recess.
Czapski's sphere of
influence was considerable.
As he settled into Maisons-Laffitte
and a life in Paris,
he had access to many key players
in the shaping of post-war Europe.
Political, religious, cultural figures,
whose doors were open to
him and who were largely
sympathetic to the fates
of the Poles in exile.
The sketch Czapski did
of de Gaulle, Malraux,
Halevy, and Jacques-Emile Blanche,
Jacques-Emile he had
met when he was in Paris
in the '20s and he continued
their relationships,
Camus he met and became a
colleague in publishing.
Camus relied on Czapski for translations
of his books in Polish, and they had
a very close and personal relationship.
In 1946, as he began to
settle into Paris life,
Czapski turned 50 just as he was about
to settle into a routine painting,
getting a discipline back,
Dierdivitch imposed upon him to go abroad
and to raise money for Kultura.
So he once again put aside his brushes
and traveled to South
America, to North America,
to raise money for the magazine,
visiting both large cities
and small Polish communities.
With him all the time was his sketchbook.
He documented all of his
trips quite thorough.
Finally, in the early 1950s,
Czapski begins to paint
and to paint in earnest,
shifting his priorities
to the studio upstairs
at the back of the house
in Maisons-Laffitte.
Here is a characteristic scene
that caught Czapski's
eyes and imagination.
What is it that makes it
worthy of being a painting?
Czapski believed that the
truth of everyday life
and the truth of art were interchangeable.
Unlike the generations
of Polish, religious,
and historical painters who constructed
heightened custom dramas,
he preferred to find humbler
subjects close at hand.
For Czapski, people waiting for a train
were capable of revealing as
much about the metaphysics
of being as any annunciation
or resurrection.
He did not go out in search of subjects.
They appeared to him as he
went about living his life,
always alert to the possible
combination of elements
that might cohere into a
memorable image in his mind's eye.
The scientists for whom
this Metro stop was named,
Louis Pasteur, once
proclaimed about research,
in the field of observation,
chance favors the prepared
mind. Czapski had such a mind.
Czapski declared that
the precision of the eye,
not the precision of the hand,
is the first and most important task.
This is a variation on
the saying of Turner,
paint What you see, not what you know.
The result was often a canvas that,
in Czapski's his own words,
could set one's teeth on edge
with a subject that could as
often as not be revolting.
He took his strength from Goya.
He noted that a great many
criticize me for painting
the filthy steps of the bazaar in Paris.
He considered Woman in Front of a Train
to be his masterpiece, although,
that changed from time to time.
Old women have a particular
fascination for him,
and he admired their tactics of survival.
Here, the woman is a cipher.
She clearly has had our share of woe.
This picture belongs to the
genre of vanitas paintings
in which a painter addresses
the transiency of life,
the certainty of death and the
folly of pleasurable pursuits.
That hat, that handbag, those shoes,
the fire on the painting is banked low,
an orange glow at the bottom of the train,
evoking a sense of embers
burning steadily inside of her.
Subdued, well beyond the flames of youth.
It's something of a tribute
to Czapski's iconoclasm
to try to call up
another painter who draws
from both Goya and Matisse
in the same painting.
Here, you can see these shoes that
Matisse is buckled on the left,
kind of echoed on the right.
So Czapski had within this
one canvas a combination
of influences and yet
his own inimitable style.
By the late '50s, he was
exhibiting regularly in Europe.
Here he is in Paris in 1959
meeting, for the first time,
the Polish poet Zbigniew Herbert.
You can see the paintings scattered
around the room on the wall,
and you can see also
the figure of the man,
how tall he is, he towers over
Herbert, and how thin he is.
We'll go from now a series
of paintings from this time.
These subjects range from
still-lives to interior scenes.
You can imagine Czapski
coming out of the door
of an apartment onto the landing
and looking down and seeing this.
He sketched it in his diary and
made several versions of it.
And this is the final painting.
There's something about the headlessness
of the figure that is curious and became
something of a trope in his work.
Again, one wonders what prompts
Czapski to capture an image
many of us might otherwise
have turned away from.
He claims to have come across
an absolute absence of bias,
a willingness to know and understand
as many opposing states of
the human soul as possible,
a capacity for discovering
in the lowest of man
such nobility as to appear sublime,
and in the seemingly purest of
beings, the basest instincts.
Czapski shares this breadth
of curiosity and fascination.
A sequence of entries on
the pages of his diary.
I bought a whole bunch of
lilies, sometimes my own vision,
which being ravished has intensified,
almost forcing itself on me,
frees me, unifies me internally.
But for that to happen I
need access to deeper waters
to counter the flow of the ravishment.
These waters, I haven't gotten.
How often does this ravishment
improve a sterile ground,
or cause a failure in a back and down?
I wait, not having the power in me
to make this leap forward,
to attack the canvas.
I want to paint the lilies
in a very modest picture,
to apply in a single go
some perfect juxtapositions
of brown, of velvety red,
the green of the leaves,
the white of the flower,
all of that is so beautiful.
It stops me.
Czapski was always a painter of doubt.
He doubted his own abilities,
and he doubted what he was able to produce
and whether or not it had value.
He was very hard on himself.
And yet this struggle, this
internal struggle, urged him on.
He had an enormous furnace with him,
burning with the desire
to remove the vision
from within him and put it onto the page.
Painting of his sister, (indistinct).
He did portraits. He
had people sit for him
to keep his discipline, his hand.
He disliked formal commission portraiture,
but he did it knowing that it
could bring positive results
in terms of commissioned work or sales.
Here are two formal portraits he did.
One of Herbert and the other of
the Portuguese writer Ferrata Mora.
The fascination with the hands
of the writers is, to
me, of great interest.
This is a self portrait in which Czapski
looks out at us circumspectly,
not quite open faced,
but present, handsome.
Without his truncated
eyeglasses, he's unflustered,
suggesting, my glasses have broken?
Well, yes. Okay, it's not a big deal.
The picture he's looking out of is shown
at the easel on the right.
Everything appears rather matter of fact
with the light bulb floating, swimming
like a Monet Waterlily in a lake
of luminous effects behind his head.
Is the subject of the
painting the painter's head
or the bulb, or the space between them?
There seems to be an
acknowledgement of shared territory,
a fullness and of emptiness,
of being and nothingness,
existing together at one side-by-side,
neither one state nor
the other prevailing.
The atmosphere of the painting,
fueled by almost ecstatic
verse strokes put down
with great effervescence,
raises existential questions after
the fashion of Beckett and Giacometti,
both of whom exerted powerful influences
on Czapski at this time.
He was able to catch psychological states,
often pulling out of the sitter something
that perhaps they didn't mean to reveal.
The painting on the right
is one of the first examples
that would become the genre for Czapski
of painting people looking at paintings.
Somehow he became so
involved with the work
that he was at museums,
he would go to galleries,
and not only the work itself,
but the engagement of
the people with the work
of art became significant to him
and became a subject of many works.
Here, a young man stands in front
of an abstract painting
by Nicholas de Stael.
It is an example of his
attempt to reconcile
non-representational
abstraction with his own work,
putting up an abstract
painting into a painting
of the figure so that you get both.
This is a time in Paris where abstraction,
non-representational expression,
became almost (indistinct),
and Czapski resisted it
for many reasons, for as long as he could.
He tried to understand it,
but he was not drawn to it.
Here, his sketches of
people looking at works
that he did in museums and
galleries throughout Paris.
His books were filled with such drawings.
Here in the center is
a self portrait of him
as an older man looking at a painting.
The awareness of himself and others
as they engaged with works of art.
This painting was done
after visiting a Corbett
retrospective at the Grand Palais.
Czapski gets the opportunity to paint
not only what he sees, but to
paint the Corbett's as well.
And to reduce them to a certain
kind of essence of vision.
The technique of brushing
so loosely in this
was at a time when the same free immersion
in what might be called
abstract expressionists'
technique was happening in New York.
Painters like Philip
Guston and Grace Hartigan
embodied the use of that
technique with narrative
paintings that is very
close to Czapski's heart.
He did not know their
work. Here's an example.
A detail of the way
the paint was put down.
Every brushstroke, you must
remember, requires a decision.
Vision, Czapski wrote, is a
shock where willful choice
between this or that is powerless.
A miracle of beauty,
which one alone can see,
unique, fleeting, imperceptible,
or even held up to ridicule by others.
Very characteristic
choice of subject matter.
The sense of presence and absence,
the hope of transcendence and the spark
of those yellow orange dabs of paint.
In 1980, Czapski turned 84.
He continued to work attacking the canvas
with more gusto and buoyant energy.
Painting was a necessity for him,
as essential as breathing and thinking.
His eyesight began to diminish radically,
but his appetite for
work was unquenchable.
As is true from (indistinct),
encroaching blindness spurred him
on to new depths of seeing.
He kept his tubes of paint in envelopes
with the name of the color
scrawled in his large hand
to facilitate identification as he worked.
In his book, Late Style,
the critic Edward Said wrote,
late style is what happens if art
does not abdicate its
rights in favor of reality.
The paintings Czapski
made in his final years
reveal a harnessing of his vision
and a clarity of purpose few can match.
In a time of physical decline,
he was somehow gaining momentum.
He persisted in his quixotic fashion.
Each canvas was a testimony and a victory.
When his beloved sister Maria died,
he wrote in his diary, before I die,
I would like to have a time of painting
in the high heat of work.
He did have his time and he
worked it for all it was worth.
He began a series of landscape paintings
in the early '80s as his
eyesight was beginning to wane.
In this canvas called Cloudburst,
the trembling sky holds a
gathering of meteorological
factors, a highly dramatic,
almost operatic scene.
Here, atmosphere has
been triggered to change.
The sky is vaporous,
animated, insubstantial.
A puff ball of cloud hovers,
sparking a kind of enchantment
like a Shakespearean sprite.
Something magical emerges.
Czapski wrote to a friend,
what's surprising is
that I'm still painting.
Each time I start a canvas,
I have the feeling that
I'm fooling the audience
since I can see almost nothing.
The touch of Czapski's brush is fearless
whipping across the canvas
like the wind blowing over a field.
Diminished eyesight freed him
from a certain tyranny of form.
It's as though he is letting
his brush do the seeing.
Loading it up with color he
let's it play across the canvas,
seeming to show him what it is
he's seeing as it moves along.
Several of the landscapes
do verge on pastoral cliche,
but his response to what he sees
is always free and unencumbered.
The painting seem to inhale
vision and exhale color.
Czapski looked out on a moral universe.
He was never indifferent to what he saw.
Trees and fields spoke their truth to him,
revealing in a way you
could be in the world
beyond the storied failings of man.
He spent his summers in
(indistinct) walking every day,
sketchbook in hand, striding out among
the open farmland and rolling hills.
Landscapes he painted in these years
presented allegorical
marriage of the bucolic
and the impenetrable, embodying an almost
biblical tension between
innocence and knowledge.
The process was referred to
by the critic William Epson
as putting the complex into the simple.
These works are unselfconscious
in a new way, poetic, empathic, pure.
Here's Czapski in his room,
with a self portrait done.
You'll see on the far right
side of the photograph,
the lower shelf has stacks of books
leaning up one against each other.
These are his diaries that
he always kept at hand.
He slept in the bed he's sitting on now
with his head to the
wall and every morning
he would reach up and grab at random
one of those journal volumes.
He would read what he had written
at some point in the past.
And he would often annotate his response
to what he had read and
then find the latest journal
and begin his day fresh with new musings.
In 1981, martial law
was declared in Poland.
Solidarity was banned and many
of its leaders were jailed.
A black and white
photograph of five prisoners
walking on a routine exercise break
under a makeshift knitting
of prison security
was smuggled out of Poland
and made the rounds,
distributed to the world's press.
Czapski was moved to make
a painting of something
he had not seen with his own eyes.
He had left Krakow for Paris in 1924
to sever all relations
with the overblown style
of historical painting, but
here he made one of his own,
limiting his palette to the
mixture of black and white.
Draining all color out
of the image also hinted
at the Western European idea of life
in a Soviet satellite
nation, a dismal prospect.
Bleak, dystopian, the feeders
appear weary and vulnerable.
For 40 years, this painting
hung in the hallway
leading to Czapski's
room in Maisons-Laffitte.
I like to think of this late canvas
as a companion piece to
Titian's great late painting,
the Flaying of Marsyas.
Full of emotional strength,
exuding negative capability.
The narrative elements are all there,
but as Morandi's quiet still lives,
the picture is hardly about any of them.
The surface is all rough and stumbled.
Almost whimsical, the
picture also gives us
the strong whiff of what the French
call (speaking in French),
the kind of progressive
awareness of one's mortality.
We see the painters thighs and
knees, the tips of his shoes.
He's engaged in viewing
an exhibit of paintings.
Each reduced to a crude
rectangle with a yellow line
around it indicating a frame.
The particular paintings hung on display
don't matter any more than
the identity of the painter.
The painting is a study
of Czapski's sacred space,
his temple, his place of worship,
his attempt to delineate the boundless
boundaries of the realm of art,
a vast and anonymous
expanse of the imagination,
greater than any specific
work or individual.
In the '50s, Czapski had painted
a subceded soprano singing (indistinct).
Here, 35 years later, he
painted himself, as it were,
singing the same, and is
both audience and performer.
The gallery has no fourth wall.
One of his latest paintings done.
You can see this. His eyesight
is really very minimal.
There's a detail of it.
In an essay called What
Abstract Art Means To Me,
Willem de Kooning conjectured that art
used to be about what
would put in a picture.
Then the time came when
the question was not
of what one could paint,
but what one could not.
He went on to say that subject matter
is the forever mute part of the picture.
You can talk about it forever.
Here's Czapski in his room in his studio
with his desk, with his
diary, with his paintings
crammed one up against another,
fearless, going on full bore.
Czapski never understood why
he had not suffered the same
tragic end of his fellow prisoners.
Two years before his death,
a year after the fall of communism,
he was informed by a
Russian historian in 1991
that a certain Countess Patapsco
and Count Ferdinand (indistinct),
who had held sway with
the German high command
during the war, had
interceded to save his life.
They convinced the officers
that people born in the areas
annexed by Nazi Germany fell under
the jurisdiction of the Third Reich.
Czapski was born in Prague.
As part of that, apparently
their influence was strong
enough to have the command
agree and they may have
added his name to a list
of those to be spared.
The MKVD received the list from German
embassy on March 5th, 1940,
the very day the
Politburo signed the order
leading to the murder of
22,000 Polish officers
just a month before the executions began.
Czapski didn't recognize
either of the two names.
Though it may well be true,
this report is ultimately unverifiable.
So many people wanted to know why Czapski
was not among those who
would be sacrificed,
but in my opinion, appearing on a list
of lives to be spared, the Polish officer,
and an titled aristocrat to boot,
would have seemed more likely to have made
the MKVD want to kill him than otherwise.
These are Czapski's late journals,
bought at an art supply store in Paris,
where coincidentally I was also
living and bought my supplies.
Same time in the '80s and late '70s.
A few days before his death,
he scribbled in an awkward
handwriting of a blind man,
the words Bonnard,
Matisse, Goya, and Proust.
And then in capital letters,
across many pages, the word Katyn.
Here on the last page of his
nearly 300 surviving volumes
of his lifelong journal
are his final marks,
the strokings of a pen on a sheet of paper
by a blind man in search of reassurance
that making a mark is a valuable activity,
that it makes a difference. Thank you.
- Thank you, Eric, for
bringing to our audience
and to our class a sense
of the man and of his work
that otherwise would
certainly have escaped us.
Thank you for bringing to bear
so humbly and so persuasively
your skills as a historian
of art and as an artist.
I feel like from this, we have
what I'd hoped we would have,
which is an entirely
different angle of view,
which is itself about
what it means to see,
which was Czapski's
lifelong preoccupation.
I think I forgot when I introduced you
to remind the audience that the way
we ask questions is by putting your name,
someone correct me if necessary,
using the question and
answer function down below,
or by using the chat and
writing down questions.
I didn't tell anyone this so I don't
think I have any questions yet,
which opens up for me the possibility
of abusing the privilege of the chair
and asking you the first one.
I'm going to give the students time
to think about how they might ask
questions related to the class.
One thing which, you know, is fairly clear
in your presentation, although
you don't say it outright,
is that Czapski got better.
He was better in middle-age as a painter
than he was as a young
man, I believe fair to say.
And then one could even
say that as a very old man,
he might've been better than
he was when he was in middle age.
And so I want to ask you if I'm
understanding you correctly.
I mean, I realize that
better than, worse than,
are not words that are just
reached to with alacrity,
but forgive my primitive
way of putting it.
I want to ask you if I'm
understanding you correctly.
And I also want to ask
you your views about why.
Of course, in the context of this class,
we're thinking about Soviet
camps and incarceration
in general and experience and Czapski
does have this, you know,
there's a striking fact
that he can't really
paint for roughly a decade
because of the Second World War
and the things he felt called upon to do,
and that he returns to
painting after 10 years.
And that he's much more interesting,
I think, when he returns to it.
That must have something to do
with not being able to paint.
It must have something
to do with the camps.
And I guess the riddle would be,
or the question I want
to put you directly is,
what is your feeling
about that relationship?
Like, in some sense, Czapski as a creator,
with the few exceptions,
one of which you showed,
the 1981 martial law painting.
He's not someone who is, you know,
except when he is directly
rendering something in the camps,
he's not a painter who's bringing
the camps out into the world, right?
So there's not that kind of simple
relationship, but there must be some.
And I wonder if in all of
your thinking about this,
you would share with us what you think
that relationship might've been?
- There are a few questions in there,
and I will try if I can to answer
them in the order they were asked.
About whether or not Czapski
got better as a painter.
I feel that Czapski was
enormously privileged
to be able to live 97 years, you know.
He had the arc of a painter that
is quite considerable,
and he was a slow starter.
When he was in Paris,
he felt very frustrated
because the group of Polish painters
around him all made enormous strides,
and he felt that he
was constantly treading
in place and not making progress.
By the time he got back to Warsaw,
I think he had an increase
in confidence in himself.
I think some of this is
about one's relationship
to one's taking on a lifetime of painting
and whether or not one is
qualified to actually do that.
And I think by the time
he got back to Warsaw
in the '30s, he felt emboldened.
The companion experience
of writing about painting,
I think, freed up a
certain part of division
in him because he could talk about it
and almost extract it from his mind
that freed his eyes to see something.
So he was developing and he was
finding what his subject is,
the same way a singer
finds his voice, I think.
And it was a very slow process,
which was brutally interrupted
just as it was beginning
to kind of coalesce when he left in 1939.
It was a very sterile
decade that followed.
In terms of painting, he painted one
painting in Baghdad that remains
a landscape of a street scene in Baghdad.
But primarily he was reduced
to pen and pencil and paper,
and he made enormous use of that.
I think the lack of paint
enabled him to embody
what for him had always
been the ideal that Saison
determined was that you
should draw with color,
draw directly with color rather than draw
with line and then paint in with color.
And this is all of those
10 years of growing
enabled him to see the
confidence that he could have,
that he could ultimately,
when he got back to paint,
he could just jump in and
paint directly with the color.
And that's in the '50s when his work
really begins to go off, I
think he was at that point
not so much concerned about the quality
of the work as it was
the subject of the work.
What was he being called to paint?
And this brings up another part
of the question that you had,
how does a painter determine
what it is that his subject is?
And it took a very long time
for Czapski to find this,
but it was ongoing and all the time.
And it was about the doubt that he had
internally that he would try
one subject after another.
But I think that you're correct
in saying that as he got older,
the forces began to come together in him.
And he somehow, I think with the beginning
of the loss of sight, when he turned 80,
the 15 years at the end of his life
were the most remarkable
late flowering of painting
that I can imagine because not only
was it a maturing of a vision,
but it was really the beginning
of confidence as a painter,
and the body of work from 1980 to 1990
is both massive and empowered.
And as I said about Edward Said saying
that it is a late style that has to do
with commitment to art
rather than reality.
And so he was able to give up the things
that had held him back
before about naturalism
or about vision and just to embody
the painting to become a painter.
- Yeah. I mean, he was a man who had
a lot of reality to give up.
- Right, and that's also
part of your questions.
What about the camps and
how did that impact him?
I think he was determined not to become
a chronicler in paint of those years.
And I think he unfortunately
was in a position
where he had to become
a chronicler in words,
in literary form, but he was determined
not to make that the
subject of his paintings.
And that was part of a
duality that existed in him
for a long time and it
took him a very long time
to honor the ability to
paint from within himself,
somehow not being selfishly self-absorbed,
which he could not afford to be otherwise.
- Yeah, and in our class,
we now have to have some
nice questions from students
that I'm going to serve
up, but in our class,
we're reading a bit of
Inhuman Land, as you know,
and having read the correspondence
between between him and Hering,
it's very clear just how much he suffered.
It was obviously difficult
to return to the period,
but he wasn't a writer. He
didn't see himself as a writer.
I mean, he was a wonderful writer,
but he didn't see himself as a writer.
It was hard for him. It
was difficult for him.
He felt that like, as you
suggest, this was the wrong genre.
Somehow he was in the
wrong artistic orbit.
This was not what he
was meant to be doing.
And, you know, the product,
the Inhuman Land book,
is a result of such struggle,
not just struggle
because of the substance,
but also struggled because of the form.
And that doesn't come through,
but it even exists as a kind of testimony
to his determination which also comes out
in the ability to just keep painting
decade after decade after decade
after decade after decade.
I mean, go ahead, sorry.
- I was going to say he writes
very clearly like a painter.
That's very good, but he was determined
not to paint like a writer.
- Yeah. Yes. That's beautiful.
Okay. I'm going to give to
the floor now to our students.
One of our students begins with
actually a classic question
and one on which my own perspective
has changed, partly thanks to your work.
One of our students asked,
is Czapski remembered as
the historical figure,
as the chronicler, as the survivor,
or is he remembered as the artist?
And I think part of the question is,
should he remember it
as a historical figure,
or should he be remembered as the artist?
- It's a very complicated
question. A very good question.
It depends upon who's
doing the remembering.
I think when I first went to Poland
to begin researching this in 2013,
people in Poland were not
really aware of Czapski
as anything but a historical figure.
He was known as the survivor of Katyn,
he was the one who carried the torch.
If anything, he was admired for what
seemed to be his national pride,
which was not at all how he
really experienced his life.
In those years since then,
I think what I've been able to find
is a greater interest in
his work as a painter,
because in Poland, the
standards of visual arts
are very much controlled by the past,
by the relation to the past,
there's an enormously freeing and powerful
graphic arts part of Polish art world.
But the painting itself
is very much not unlike
what Czapski faced when he was
in the academy in the '20s.
There is this tradition,
and then there is the kind of fashionable,
and Czapski seems somehow
now to speak to people
more directly because
pf his individualism,
which was considered
a weakness earlier on,
but it's now considered a strength.
So I do think that Czapski
is an exceptional painter.
I'm not making a case for
him being a great painter.
For me, his life, his devotion
to painting is really what's key.
I don't think you can
put him on a platform.
There are many great painters.
There's a question here also of market.
There's no real market value for Czapski.
So it's very hard to assess
him in terms of his greatness,
because in the current art world,
greatness is predicated
upon auction prices,
and Czapski certainly doesn't appear
in the stratosphere that way,
whereas his work represents
a certain accomplishment
that I find very inspiring
and very meaningful.
And I think more and more
young people are beginning
to recognize his work
and gravitate towards it.
- The next question I would
ask you from a second student,
I'm just going to ask it in her words
'cause I think she's onto
something which is very important
and it compliments what we
were just talking about.
During his time in imprisonment,
Czapski experienced
absence in a profound way.
The men he saw one day were gone the next.
In what ways do you
think that has exposure
to systemic loss or removal
informed his artistic style,
specifically his fixation on the subject?
- On the subject?
Well, Czapski's mother
died when he was six
and the sensation of loss is something
that he's known his entire life.
I think that it informs everything
in an aesthetic sense with him,
that the idea of absence and presence,
that dichotomy, that kind of
attempt to show the unseen,
all of those revolve around this tentative
relationship to the world around us.
I think he is profoundly
immersed in a world of loss
and his role, his life
work, like Ludwig Hering,
is not to be eclipsed
by that sense of loss,
not to be crippled by
it, but to understand it
and to use it as a generative force.
- Okay, another student asks,
much of Czapski's art seemed to center
the act of looking,
especially looking at art.
Do the body languages and facial
expressions of the figures
in his paintings convey
anything about his own attitude
about looking critically
or looking closely?
- Well, I think that
became a subject for him
is clear that yes, it
was very important to him
and it tells a great deal about
his involvement in that world.
I think he celebrated reactive looking.
The monograph that I put
together of his work,
I call an apprenticeship of looking,
which was his term for
what he didn't consider
that he had a career as a painter.
He never valued himself that highly.
He always thought of it,
what he called as an
apprenticeship he had of looking,
and looking, (indistinct) said,
is the longest of all the
apprenticeships in the arts.
And that's really very
true. So this is what he is.
Again, celebrating this
idea of the engagement
of a viewer with the work of art.
And also his is an
opportunity to have that time,
not just lost in the
contemplation of a work of art,
he wanted to keep it active.
So he would step back from the painting
and see the room that he was in.
See the gallery, see the
people who were involved, also.
- Some of the remaining questions
are on overlapping themes
and some of them, I think we can best
address in class
tomorrow, and we have made
you work not for 90 years,
but for at least 90 minutes,
which is a good chunk of time.
I want to thank you again, Eric,
first of all for all of
the work you have done
to bring Czapski to the world,
you have begun a renewal,
which I hope will continue.
And I hope this lecture in this class
will do something towards bringing his way
of looking at things that
everyone should care about
closer to the center of conversations.
I want to thank you for entertaining
the questions of our class.
I want to thank students for
engaging with this difficult
material after their previous difficult
material and for being with us.
And I want to thank all of our guests,
for our numerous guests,
for joining us in this Franke lecture.
So I'm Timothy Snyder.
We've been listening to Eric Karpeles
and I'm very pleased, very happy,
that we could bring all of
this together in the framework
of the Franke lectures and the framework
of this class. So thank you again, Eric.
- Thank you very much to everyone involved
and I respect and appreciate the work
that's being done by you and the class
and the idea of bringing this material
to a bigger world and a
deeper understanding of it.
So thank you very much.